[Music]
foreign
America we show how people and
communities are working together to
Build a Better World this morning we're
focusing on communities Fighting Food
waste why
because around one-third of food in the
U.S is never eaten most ends up in
landfills where it generates the potent
greenhouse gas methane but cities across
the country are now turning to compost
programs to put that waste to work for
the environment Lilia Luciano met up
with one convert on a mission to make
composting cool even in unexpected
places starting with the communities
that raised him
good
growing up in New York City's public
housing Domingo Morales was more focused
on his personal sustainability than that
of the environment I was in and out of
foster care it was just about you know
making money how to get the next
job
but his perspective turned around when
he took a job composting on a community
Farm in Brooklyn we went three times a
week to shovel to shovel to shovel and
then a couple months after we were
sifting finished compost and they
allowed us to apply finished compost to
the farm and I'm like whoa you can
recycle food waste that aha moment for
Morales prompted him to get his hands
dirty and gain a better understanding of
the art of composting that's good the
nutrient-rich combination of food scraps
and yard waste is like a meal for garden
soil which then feeds and nourishes
plants it also reduces methane emissions
by keeping food out of landfills so you
were kind of moving dirt not sure what
you were doing and suddenly you were
able to see the connection from that
pile to here to the farm it just made
sense to me it clicked it's like
recycling plastic I still don't get it
recycling metal I still don't get it I
know what happens with compost Morales
teamed up with the non-profit Green City
force and the New York City Housing
Authority to form compost power an
initiative building up composting
efforts in public housing communities
once a week we'll come and we'll
actually aerate this pile his
human-powered system requires several
people to turn piles of waste in three
different stages of decomposition it is
physical work but you won't hear any
complaints from his team it was based
like a workout session for me I'm trying
to show that small scale composting can
change Behavior but on top of that I'm
trying to show that it's possible in the
communities that historically people
said it wasn't compost power isn't alone
in its Mission New York City has
earmarked 2.7 million dollars to roll
out compost collection bins throughout
the borough of Queens I love that I
don't have to buy a lot of trash bags
anymore so residents like Jasmine
McPherson can put food in yard waste out
with their trash and recycling once you
start properly throwing away your waste
you'll see a reduction in how much money
you consciously spend because you're
seeing what you're throwing away what
you're not eating
back in Brooklyn Morales is busy feeding
a balanced diet to his miniature special
agents fungi bacteria and insects which
he calls the FBI it's one part
nitrogen-packed greens from food scraps
and three parts carbon heavy materials
so we got wood chips here the whole
process takes up to six weeks assistant
tables basically where you finalize the
compost and the finished compost then
feeds the vibrant Farm in the heart of
this community Campos is a big important
part for what we do we need them more
than they need us what grows there is
free for residents at one Farm Stand we
had cucumbers that were longer than 12
inches oversized red radishes the
eggplants they were gigantic and they
bring their food scraps in exchange
which along with the farm waste
replenishes the compost pile if we can
show that in a large community like this
we can make it a culture no one has an
excuse he says if you can compost here
you can compost anywhere for CBS
mornings Lilia Luciano New York